et voici balbutiements d'un futur grand
à l'avenant pour son roman feu mon
histoire d'amour chez berger les ans
grâce à la bonne entente qui publie chez
grasset un livre formidable
l'armée je le pense sincèrement qu'ils
s'appellent feu mon histoire d'amour
c'est un troisième livre le 31
très fracassante dans la littérature
française la chance d'être tombé sur un
nourricier sur un directeur de la
fabrication chez grasset qui sait très
bien démerdé parce qu'avec tout texte
il arrive à faire 120 pages non parce
que le b mais le livre est conçu comme
ça son livre a été accueilli par une
critique dithyrambique drieu aux crs mns
besson c'est déjà bien
et puis morand mort entre acteurs des
débuts de l'époque 21 22
nourissier jeunes aragon nous dit ravi
pour les mauvaises enfants
frais début octobre a été citée besoin
d'un débit et bien entendu tibi nac m'a
fait quelque chose de très bien dans le
côté malicieux taquin
nouveautés devant d'un passé des beaux
des censiés de la faire
alors que notait le côté daniel
désinvolte ce serait se tromper c'est ce
que je suis mais estimé un élément
gravité exemple tu dis les femmes sont
la meilleure paire à petit comme à
lequel nous ferons la phrase est clair
la phrase est clair il suffit de la de
la cité à l'éclair
les femmes sont la meilleure
thérapeutique ou mal qu'elles nous font
si elles nous ont fait du mal
[Musique]
ou bien dramatiser un petit peu un il
patio qu'elle nous fasse du bien de
temps et
la tige un petit peu on a aimé ton comme
nous et fait du mal bien refaire ce
souci
pour lui écrire
alors
d'autres femmes comme thérapeutique
thérapeute qui tu dis un moment quand
même mais en parlant de toi dans le
bouquin est sur le point de devenir un
très bon écrivain français ce qui est
tout à fait vrai d'ailleurs en façade et
montre une ville aux annonces confiance
en soi total d'existence moi je n'ai pas
le choix mais pas choix tu veux que je
fasse un je me pose la question si
plutôt que de vouloir devenir grand et
grimages n'aurait pas mieux fait d'aller
traire les vaches à mains nues qui c'est
un endroit où il ya des vaches dans les
ardennes à maggie on est joueur
tricolore a fait un enfant je sais plus
été condamné à devenir un grand écrivain
condamné à réussir si je vais être
honnête avec moi même c'est une question
d'honnêteté à part condamné est un grand
écrivain si je suis au nahd si j'écris
si je suis honnête j'écris de bons
livres
si j'ai fait de bons livres je serai
forcément un écrivain qui aura quelqu'un
pourtant tort est ce que tu es prêt pour
l'interview vous ou je suis pas prêt du
tout
chardonne alors mais mettre à écrire ce
sont jean paulhan et jacques chardonne
vendu beaucoup de mal jacques chardonne
on dit que si lui c'est une écriture de
réactionnaire c'est qu'il est d'une
autre époque mais qu'on lise clair donc
quand les
je sais pas la seconde partie de l'année
jacques chardonne vivre à madère lettre
à roger nimier chimérique
quand les cela enfin après on discutera
alors le mettre à écrire ce genre
collant programme d'amour assez lent
comment le gard y appliquer programme
d'amour assez lent la lie on trouve tout
ça dans la collection imaginaire chez
gallimard
et en ce moment la vie et plein de
choses redoutables collection seghers le
journal
[Applaudissements]
jean paulhan jean paulhan c'est
quelqu'un qui s'avançait à et toutes ses
faiblesses face aux femmes comment
ce qui se demandaient s'il n'était pas
un peu fou moi je me demande quelquefois
quand j'écris les lettres extravagantes
aux dames si je ne suis pas un peu
malade ni mieux ni nier ça lui sert
bleus c'est le grand d'espagne c'est
peut-être les épais quelqu'un qui m'a
projet qui a laissé au volant
qui as est conduit en jeune femme qui
n'aurait pas dû patrick besson
papé de naissance est un chef-d'oeuvre
lettre à un ami en chattant bijou est
acceptable tout va bien patrick besson
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui a commencé
par écrire des
il veut être un ami perdu c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre qui arrive à 30 ans où il
doit reprendre se vendent sous reparti
une affaire entendue et eric eric neuf
c'est quelqu'un qui fait trop de
journalisme etiassé l'élégance n'est
ouais c'est l'élégance
il peut tout écrire de façon simple et
élégant c'est l'élégance n'est qu'ils
fassent moins du journal et ses fans
figaro comment mon petit mano figaro
comment on peut dire je te vois déjà toi
hein quand comment vous pouvez tenir
il n'y arrivait pas marc edouard nabe
marque de la nacelle
c'est quelqu'un à qui je dirais il n'y a
pas de jénine aussi c'est pas dans c'est
pas dans l'idiot international que marc
edouard nabe est un grand timide en ces
veilles tél c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est
un garçon que j'aime moi je n'hésite pas
à prendre le risque de lire la
télévision après tu cites un personnage
de ton livre qui aiment trois écrivains
et dont tu dis qu'ils sont des vieux
garçons et que le fait de grippe et
génère fait un cadeau
le fait de les aimer finalement démontre
goût petit bourgeois alors ces trois les
trois vieux garçon il ya jean edern
hallier tout il m'a téléphoné en me
disant alain bonhomme vous êtes un grand
écrivain politique internationale n'est
pas la peine de le dire ouais et il n'en
voyait naître dernièrement surpris du
internationale effectuée dans la revue
des demandes je peux pas tout faire
je n'ai pas raison d'en vouloir bernard
henri lévy pour les idées bon mais quand
je le vois pour
donnez un article figaro et que comme
photo il donne une photo de vie où il ya
devant les derniers jours de charles
baudelaire je me dis ça malhonnête
intellectuellement ça ne va pas on ne
peut pas faire des choses comme ça bon
et cela je le vois de ma compagne de
reims 1
alors la meilleure chose à faire c'est
de prendre ses distances
philippe sollers tu dis que c'est un
philips a raté des chercheurs étudient
qu'il faut surtout puis mythe
ce qu'il n'a pas fait philippe sollers
est curieux je fais des références je
rends service ou le solaire c'est un
ligne youtube de solitude absolue devant
le lycée des prêtres souvent très bon
lire
et puis plus rien pour rien l'homme est
intelligent de donner des effets
remarquables n'écrit pas de
chef-d'oeuvre c'est un raté du
chef-d'oeuvre s'il dit qu'il écrit des
shadows c'est un raté les chefs-d'oeuvre
points coué n'a par contre plus tard qui
était abondamment défendu c'est par la
france
d'un frein qui sait ce que c'est c'est
une fois l'académie française pour si tu
vas y aller avec les blessures
si les femmes même moteur qu elle même
peu en ce moment et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu